it's been a wonderful opportunity for us
to just really step in other people's
shoes and be sensitive to them and want
to effect positive change we're gonna
reveal to the family with a pregnant
gingerbread so we have little trees and
there's ginger today we are making
master the whole bit
this old Kobe thing it's just nothing
like we've ever seen in our lifetime you
can't give them a hug it's just
different so the new season of counting
on starting with a special quarantine
episode what are the fans gonna see it
we've seen in the trailer you guys
making masks for everybody what will the
fans see about how your family handled
the news of the pandemic yeah it's it's
been a fascinating time for everybody
and I think everybody is just trying to
make the best of it and still be a
family and spend time together and so
you'll see some family gatherings of
everyone socially distanced and I guess
kind of like a yeah family night buy a
video chat which is and but a lot of
people have been you know that's the new
reality right so everybody's been kind
of adjusting to that so yeah a family of
a lot of people trying to adjust to
central well and I mean ginger look
everybody's follow to your family for
years and years and you guys are so
close what is it like to not be able to
hug each other and spend as much time
with each other emotionally for
everybody yeah my family is definitely
super close and so I think for us we
live in LA and so we are already you
know that distance is already there so
for us it provides even more
opportunities to get together with the
family of our video chat then even
usually we get to but I know for them
I've heard from my siblings it's been
really difficult for them to be
separated stay in their own homes and
just try to call in wherever they can
and so I think if they're just all
trying to make the best of it yeah well
you guys always do that and you also
always get together and chip in on work
that needs to be done we've seen that
over the years so you see everybody
making the masks what's that
did that just seem like a natural fit
for for your fam yeah my family
definitely with the masks they're all
excited to jump in and just have a
family project
you know if the family project is not
outside touch whatever they could do
inside together they were all about it
so you guys have made the big move to LA
what's it been like for you I'm sure the
pandemic of course affected everything
but how are you feeling yeah it's been
good honestly ginger and I really enjoy
Los Angeles it's it's honestly felt like
coming home we have a lot of great
friends out here we've enjoyed the city
we got about six or seven months of
exploring the city and you know want to
hang out before before the pandemic but
even then it's just been really sweet to
be out here so we're enjoying it and
yeah looking forward to maybe the season
passing and being able to kind of go
outside again and spend more time with
friends and explore the city it's really
been a good year I've lived in Illinois
and Missouri Ellie's a different breed
how are you guys finding LA in terms of
when you could do that exploring did you
see things you'd never seen or have new
experiences versus life in Arkansas in
Texas well definitely different yeah
that's different we both love it so I
think LA for us is just an amazing
adventure we love it love exploring new
places seeing new sights honestly I
think we feel more at home in a city
like this we love the cultural diversity
we love having the opportunity to be I
mean in our in our neighborhood here I
think it's 47% of various ethnic
backgrounds and so it's just a really
cool atmosphere and yeah we were living
in Texas but neither of us are Texans
they're cowboy cowboy no no don't say
y'all I mean ginger said y'all
times and I forgave her but it was never
this so so honestly being on in LA on
the west coast it feels more comfortable
for us I've always liked traveling did
your likes traveling so we love it here
that's great well and I mean diversity
especially with the movement that's
happening right now what kind of
discussions are you guys having or plan
to have or even discussions across the
family about raising your children with
that awareness of the importance of
different cultural backgrounds yeah
that's huge and honestly this last month
has afforded us a lot of good
conversations and we've really pause to
listen we've wanted to hear different
perspectives and it's been really
fascinating just hearing different
people's journey and hearing how people
are responding to the current events and
what their initial reaction is and why
it's their initial reaction and we have
friends who live in Charleston South
Carolina and we obviously know there's
there's a history there with the the
slave trade and hearing hearing from
their perspective and seeing everything
that happened there has been fascinating
it's been a wonderful opportunity for us
to just really step in other people's
shoes and be sensitive to them and want
to effect positive change and so it's
it's interesting really being in LA it's
kind of the center for a lot of that
conversation and ginger and I haven't
have appreciated that and I wanted to be
involved in that conversation
so yeah it's we've thought a lot about
raising felicity and you know any other
children we may have here and I think
that's an exciting prospect because you
want them to be able to see various
parts of I mean traveling is good in
some various parts of the world they're
just being able to have different
perspectives and hearing from different
people is good and so yeah that's been a
very immediate like it's super heavy
there but yeah look I mean you you guys
have had a big you know last year you
moved to LA a pandemic hits now we're in
the middle of a movement
lots of process and by the way you're
experiencing all this pregnant it's what
I have to ask you - what's the stress of
the pandemic like being pregnant I don't
know how this pregnancy has been for you
but how has it been health-wise and have
you had to be extra cautious or you
nervous at all
yes definitely at the beginning I had
morning sickness it wasn't awful like so
so terrible but when I did feel bad it
was awesome having Jer home from work
it was just working upstairs remotely
and finishing his studies for the
semester and so he was able to take care
of Felicity and I was able to go take a
nap or rest when I needed to so that was
something that was really grateful for
in this season having a little one
running around you know when I'm not
feeling so well it was awesome having
Jared here over that time and now that
I'm past that it's it still is just
wonderful like the pregnancies been
going good and it's really felt pretty
smooth I think kind of similar to
Felicity's and so I kind of know what to
expect now and so will will we see I
don't know exactly when you guys were
filming so what will we kind of see on
this season in terms of all that yeah in
the season you'll see are they moved to
LA we did a big road trip and so they'll
get all of that then follow us as we
announced to my family that I was
expecting and then also the sadness of
losing that little one and so it's just
going to be an amazing season just to
see I think the highs and then the lows
that would walk through what is it like
for you because in the moment and in the
the following weeks of course you try to
process an incredible loss like that but
then you watch it back again on the show
how does that hit you or how do you
think it will hit you hmm
yeah I think um just knowing that God
gave us this little one and
this little one was taken from us I
think it was definitely a hard thing to
deal with but God gave us grace and yeah
definitely watching that show I think
there will be a lot of emotions that
will come back up just seeing that again
but I think we're looking forward to
even the joys now of having a new little
one on the way and very excited about
that yeah I would imagine there's a
hesitancy you you feel a little bit you
know emotionally shy about really
celebrating it sounds like you felt that
a little bit that's most definitely even
telling family and friends we delayed
quite a bit more than we had even been
Felicity's and just waiting to see if
everything was okay lots of ultrasounds
and checkups and thankfully this little
one this little girl is doing great when
so many of you are pregnant together at
once it's just lean on each other and
talk about what you're going through
that's definitely I talked to my sister
joy a lot she have prior to this
pregnancy that she has she had a
miscarriage as well and so she and I had
lots of conversations and when I lost
the baby and then also now that I'm
pregnant again and we're both pregnant
at the same time it's just amazing to
have a sister who's pregnant and be able
to just bounce things off of her and
like what are your cravings you know
what are you doing yeah exercises you're
doing these days and so it's just so fun
well in what ups and downs for you guys
to go through together I mean do you
think when you look back on especially
both having gone through that loss
together is there a moment you'll
remember when even if you were on the
phone and you were able to talk or cry
together something that you will really
stick with you most definitely joy I
grown closer through this I think then
probably any other time like just we
were already close but I think that's
only deepened in the past few months
having been in the same place and with
none of my other sisters experiencing
this loss
making just to have heard and to hear
her heart to and how she walked through
the miscarriage before me and but then
also now with the pregnancy following
the miscarriage is just how she's coping
with even you know the fears that you'll
feel that come up that are real and you
just have to like trust the Lord and
yeah just be grateful for this new
little one so you guys I have to wrap up
with you but if you were going to tease
the new episodes in like one sentence
what would you tell the fans about what
they're gonna get and why they should
definitely watch yes so much is going on
this year we move across the country we
experience the death of gingers
grandmother we suffer a miscarriage but
we also have the joys of expecting a new
little one so man a lot going on this
year and what we're really excited about
is showing the world you know this
dimension of our life the good times in
Tibet yeah anything to add to that
ginger yeah I definitely think they'll
see us even in a raw form that they'd
never seen before and I just hope
through all that our heart is that
others who've walked through the same
difficulties would be able to have hope
even through all of those things
[Music]